[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 161
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Mark Mandel,
and this time I
am joined by the
wonderful Aja Hammerly.
How are you doing, Aja?
AJA HAMMERLY: Hi, Mark.
It's kind of cool to
be in the host seat
after having been a guest.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS] You get
to see the other side of things.
So before we get
stuck in today, we're
going to be talking
about a lot of cool stuff
about Go Cloud Functions.
We've got a question of the
week talking about running
containers on GCP.
But before we get
stuck into all of that,
do you want to tell people
a little bit about yourself
since it's your first
time in the host seat?
AJA HAMMERLY: So I'm Aja.
I am one of the developer
advocates on our Cloud Platform
team.
And I'm based out of Seattle.
[APPLAUSE]
It is wonderful and beautiful
and raining all the time.
MARK MANDEL: Hm.
AJA HAMMERLY: And, kind of,
my passion on Google Cloud
the last 2 and 1/2-ish years has
been figuring out the best ways
to reach out to all of those
wonderful language communities
that we support, making
sure that we're showing up
as respectful and contributing
members of the different
languages that we use,
supporting the language
community to grow and feel
welcome in our platform.
And a lot of that's
just been working
on making sure that our
products are idiomatic,
that they solve the
problems that people have,
and that we're out
there helping out
and just being good citizens.
That's something that's
really important to me,
and I'm really
lucky to work here
because I get to do
this all day every day.
MARK MANDEL: Nice, nice, nice.
Awesome.
Well, as per always
with the podcast,
we start with our cool
things of the week.
I believe you have a cool
thing of the week, Aja.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah, so in honor
of my first time in the host
seat, I have the
world's worst joke.
There is an actually
cool thing of the week.
I saw on Twitter last night
that apparently the paint
is peeling off of
our Iowa data center
because it is so cold with
the polar vortex right now.
So that is the actually
cool thing of the week.
[LAUGHTER]
To all of our listeners
who are currently
affected by freezing cold
temperatures, please stay warm.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, yes.
Definitely stay warm.
That's good for people.
[LAUGHING]
That is a cool
thing of the week.
AJA HAMMERLY: It is a very
cool thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool
thing of the week.
OK.
Awesome.
So actually, as
of, I think, today,
which is the day
we're recording,
not the day you're listening,
Cloud Firestore has
gone generally available,
which is really, really cool.
So if you're not familiar
with Cloud Firestore,
it's our serverless
NoSQL document database.
It's fully managed for
you, highly scalable,
and we're making it available
in 10 locations, as well at GA.
So Hong Kong, Mumbai, Tokyo,
Sydney, Los Angeles, Montreal,
North Virginia, South
Carolina, Sao Paulo, London,
something else I
can't read, [LAUGHS]
and a couple more locations are
coming up soon, too, as well.
So pretty exciting
that it's going
to be available everywhere, and
you can take advantage of it.
And now it's, like,
generally available,
so it's ready for use.
We have links to the show notes
for the announcement and blog
post.
So you can check out more
stuff about it in there.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
Other stuff for my cool
things of the week list
is that the site
reliability workbook is now
available in HTML.
There will be a link
in the show notes.
And this is a successor
to the original SRE book.
But this covers a
lot of the stuff
that people struggle with.
It helps-- you start
to think about how
to implement the practices
of site reliability
at your organization.
And one of the things I've
loved about the last year or so
is that I've gotten
to spend some time
just having lunch
with SREs at Google
and learning about how
they approach problems.
And it's, honestly, made me
a better person, in general.
Things like blameless
postmortems,
setting clear expectations--
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
AJA HAMMERLY: --those are just
fantastic humaning skills,
in addition to
being great skills
for running an organization
and keeping your websites up.
So I recommend
folks check it out.
There's a lot to learn there.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
I like anything that has
the word "games" in it.
There's a wonderful
article that's
come out on the Google
Cloud blog called "Building
a serverless online game--
Cloud Hero on Google
Cloud Platform."
This is an in-event sort
of party game for everyone
who is sitting in
a room, basically
to test your knowledge
of Google Cloud
through the use of
timed challenges.
To date over 1,000
people have played it.
So in the article
they actually go
through how it was built using
Angular, Cloud Firestore, Cloud
Functions, and all
the bits and pieces
and how it was put together.
So if you're interested in
how that was put together
and you think, oh,
that might apply
to some of the
things I'm building,
you should check
out the blog post,
which we'll have
in the show notes.
AJA HAMMERLY: And
my last thing is
that I read a really great
Medium article this morning
about chronic illness in tech
called "The tech industry is
failing people with disabilities
and chronic illnesses."
And this is something we
don't get to talk about a lot.
It doesn't come up in a lot of
the inclusion discussions that
are going on.
We tend to focus on racial
and gender diversity.
But this is super
important stuff.
And I learned a lot
from reading this post.
So if folks of the time, I
recommend you check it out,
just to expand your knowledge
of what inclusion needs
to look like for us to have all
of the smartest people working
on tech problems.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
Well, fantastic.
Thanks for sharing that, Aja.
Why don't we go talk
to Stewart and Tyler
and talk to them all
about Go Cloud Functions?
AJA HAMMERLY: Sounds awesome.
I can't wait to learn it.
MARK MANDEL: Today,
I am, as always,
very excited to have some
new friends on the podcast.
We have Stewart Reichling
and Tyler Bui-Palsulich--
did I get that
even vaguely right?
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH:
Yeah, it's pretty close.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
I'll take it--
coming here to talk to
us about Cloud Functions,
but very specifically,
Go Cloud Functions.
So thank you very
much for joining us.
How are you doing today, Tyler?
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH:
Thank you for having me.
I'm doing very well.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And how are you doing, Stewart?
STEWART REICHLING: Yes, yes.
Doing real good.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent,
excellent, excellent.
Well, thank you so much for
joining us on the podcast
and talking to us about
Go and Go Cloud Functions.
Before we get stuck into
things, why don't you
tell us a little
bit about yourselves
and what you do at Google
and all that good stuff?
Stewart, why don't you go first.
STEWART REICHLING:
Hey, I'm Stewart.
I'm the product manager
for Cloud Functions.
I work a lot on
bringing new languages
to the product, new features,
working with customers,
understanding their needs--
anything Cloud
Functions pretty much
runs through me on
the product side.
MARK MANDEL: Tyler?
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH: I'm Tyler.
I am a developer
programs engineer, which
is part of Developer Relations.
And my goal is to make
it as easy as possible
to run Go on Google
Cloud Platform.
AJA HAMMERLY: For
those folks who
aren't familiar with
Cloud Functions, what
exactly is Cloud Functions?
STEWART REICHLING:
Have either of you
had a chance to use
Cloud Functions?
MARK MANDEL: I have.
I write very bad
JavaScript on it.
[ROBOT BEEPING]
STEWART REICHLING: Nice.
AJA HAMMERLY: I was playing
with it yesterday afternoon
trying to transfer a
distributed computing talk
I did from a couple years
ago to Cloud Functions.
It was amazing.
[HEAVENLY CHOIR]
STEWART REICHLING: Awesome.
So it sounds like
some people have
started to get used to the
idea of Cloud Functions.
But just for those who haven't
really had a chance yet,
Cloud Functions is
one of our serverless
compute products from Google.
Now, "serverless"--
what does that mean?
That means that you give us your
code, and we run it for you.
You don't have to think
about infrastructure.
It scales automatically.
You only pay for what you use.
And what we really focus on
is having a very idiomatic
developer experience.
So making sure that, if
you're a Go developer,
it looks, it feels,
it smells like Go.
It's something that's
familiar to you.
And so the idea
with Cloud Functions
is you give us that
little bit of code,
it runs in response to
an event, and we handle
all the hard stuff for you.
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH:
One way I like
to explain it is, kind of,
in the spectrum of ways
you can run your code is you
come up with some application,
and you're running
it on your laptop.
And you say, hey, look at this.
This is so cool.
Then you say, all
right, maybe I'm
going to put this on a server.
And I'm going to stick
that in the closet,
and I'm going to keep the power
on and the air conditioning on.
And then once that gets a
little bit too cumbersome,
maybe you put a VM on-premise,
or maybe some cloud provider,
and that gets too cumbersome.
So then you have some
automatically scaling
application service,
say, Google's App Engine.
And if that's a
little bit overweight
for what you are working
on, then Functions
can be the next
step, where, instead
of writing an entire application
for what you need to do, maybe
it's just a single function
that resizes images, or does
some small concrete
task that doesn't
require an entire application
to be running somewhere.
AJA HAMMERLY: So that
sounds super cool.
I like the imagery
resizing example.
Can you give us some
other examples of stuff
that does really well
on Cloud Functions?
STEWART REICHLING: Sure.
I've got some examples
of use cases of things
that we've seen.
And all of these, kind
of, fall within the bucket
of event-driven computing.
So something happens, you
want something else to happen
in response, a sort of
programmable computing
layer when an event happens.
So for example, imagine you
have a Cron Job right now
that's running on your machine,
and it runs once a day.
Well, does it really make
sense for that machine
to be the thing where
your code lives?
And if that machine
goes down, you
have to maintain it and
figure out what's happening.
So one example use
case is you have
a product like Cloud Scheduler.
Cloud Scheduler sends an
event to Cloud Functions
on a schedule every day, for
example, and then you run code.
It might be something that goes
and looks through your database
and cleans up stale files.
It might be something that
does a data transformation
on a regular schedule.
So that's one example.
Another very common
use case I see
is gluing together
either different clouds,
or even within Google
Cloud, different services.
So you might have
events coming off
of a message bus using
Pub/Sub, for example,
and you want to move that
data from that message bus
into a more
persistent data store.
So a Cloud Function
is a very easy way
to say, OK, I get that message.
Maybe I do a very small
transformation on it,
and now I load it into my cloud
SQL or into my Cloud Firestore.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So we're here to talk
about Go Cloud Functions.
What's special about
Go Cloud Functions,
other than, I mean, I can write
Go, which is kind of cool?
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah,
so, as I mentioned earlier,
one of the things that
we really try to focus on
is having a very idiomatic
developer experience.
So that means if you write
Node, if you write Python,
if you like Go, when
you touch the product
and you use the
product, it should
feel very familiar to you.
And to help us
achieve that goal,
I actually lean very heavily
on our developer programs
engineers like Tyler because
Tyler is a Go expert.
I know these languages
reasonably well,
but I really look to
someone like Tyler
to bring his expertise when
we design this product so
that, as someone who's been
working on Go for a long time,
it should feel very familiar.
Tyler, you want to talk
a little bit about why
we think this is special?
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH:
Yeah, so one
of the important
things for me is
that writing your
application should not
be specific to where you
are running that code.
So for Cloud Functions, in
particular for HTTP functions,
a Go HTTP Cloud Function
is an HTTP HandlerFunc,
so you don't need a
third-party import.
You don't need anything special.
It's just all of the
handlers that you've
written in the past
can be run directly
on Cloud Functions with
minimal modification.
STEWART REICHLING:
Just for people
who aren't completely
familiar with the product
yet, with Cloud
Functions we, basically,
provide two ways of
invoking your function.
One is via an HTTP web hook.
That's the classic use case.
We give you HTTP signature.
We let you interact directly
with the HTTP object.
And so, in order
to implement that,
we used Go's idiomatic
standard HTTP HandlerFunc.
You send a request to
the URL that we give you,
and your code runs
in response to that.
The other way that you
can run Cloud Functions
is background
functions, or functions
that are triggered by events
emitted by Google Cloud
infrastructure, so things
like Pub/Sub, Google Cloud
Storage, Cloud Firestore.
MARK MANDEL: And
does the interface
for that look slightly
different, I assume?
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH: It
is a little bit different.
So we tried to make
it a little bit easier
to interact with those
different event types,
rather than direct HTTP.
And so the hope
is that you still
aren't writing code that does
too much heavy lifting, where
you have to parse exactly
what's in every single request.
And so what those look
like is it's a function.
It takes a standard
Go context object,
which carries information,
like request-scoped values,
deadlines, and so on.
And you have one more
argument, that is event type
that you care about.
And so our runtime
unmarshalls what
comes in as json into the
event type that you provide.
And then the function
returns an error,
which indicates, basically,
was this a success or not?
And then, based on
that return value,
you can optionally enable
retrials for your function.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah.
And so when we say "idiomatic"--
SPEAKER: What did
you just call me?
STEWART REICHLING:
--a lot of people
say, what does
that actually mean?
The goal here is that
we want to minimize
the amount of new stuff
that you have to learn
and the cognitive overhead when
you're developing something.
We want to make it super
easy and super quick, as a Go
developer, for you to be
able to write a function,
not learn anything new, deploy
it, and start seeing events
come in immediately.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm guessing
that also translates to, like,
local development experience?
If it's just a
standard HTTP handler,
I can just use standard stuff.
Is that right?
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH:
Yeah, exactly.
So the way that's
usually set up is
having a command
subdirectory, which
is a common pattern for
Go projects, in general.
And so you create that
directory, put in a package
main with an HTTP server in
there, listen for the functions
that you care about, and run it.
And I think that might
provide some friction
around connecting,
say, Pub/Sub where
you're using the real Pub/Sub
service to run your functions.
But for HTTP, it
works really well.
And testing is also really nice.
One of the other things that
we support with this runtime
is that Go 1.11 introduces
this concept of go.mod,
which allows you to specify your
dependencies in a go.mod file.
It supports Go 1.11
modules functionality.
And that, basically, brings
to the language behavior
that is very familiar
to someone who's
been using Node
with package.json
or Python with
requirements text.
And so, basically, this
allows you to just write
your dependencies in a file.
You don't have to
worry about vendoring.
You don't have to worry about
managing the actual source
code you deploy.
Our infrastructure
inspects that go.mod,
and it will install
the dependencies
and resolve those for
you in your container.
So we feel that that's
a very easy way for us
to show that we're
incorporating new Go language
features, staying up to date
with what the community is
doing, and also providing a
very simple developer experience
that is new to the language.
But we feel pretty
good about how
that's going to find a bigger
following in the future.
AJA HAMMERLY: So Google has
a lot of serverless products.
How exactly is Cloud
Functions different than,
say, App Engine?
When would I want to
choose one or the other?
STEWART REICHLING: Sure.
So there are a lot of
similarities between the two
products.
I talked earlier
about not having
to manage infrastructure,
really paying for the resources
that you're using, scaling
up and down to zero.
So if you're getting no
traffic, you're not paying.
But there are also some
pretty key differences.
And the way I like to
think about it is you
want to use the right
tool for the right job.
So App Engine is really
well suited for web apps.
You're setting up a store that
has multiple different routes,
and you want to
make sure that when
you get a request
to a certain route,
you render a certain
page back to your user.
Cloud Functions is really all
about the event-based use case,
so you're not, necessarily,
setting up multiple routes.
You are writing
single-purpose code
that scales automatically
and responds
to the incoming event load.
And we try to make
that clear, also,
through the feature
sets that are provided
with the different products.
So for example, App Engine--
very well integrated
with custom domains.
You want to put your storefront
behind a domain that's
yourstore.com.
Cloud Functions-- very good
integration with events.
You issue one command to deploy.
It gets wired up to Pub/Sub.
And now, all of a
sudden, you're already
getting that event stream.
You don't have to handle a
bunch of additional wiring.
Tyler alluded to
automatic retries,
and that's also a pretty
big feature for us.
So if you're getting
events, occasionally you're
handling those events,
and your function
might fail for whatever reason.
Maybe you have a flaky
backend that that function's
interacting with.
You want to make sure that you
have a very easy way for you
to recover from those failures,
and you can potentially
retry that event.
Cloud Functions comes
with retries, sort of,
built in as a first-class
primitive because it's
important to the
events use case.
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH:
Another advantage
is that with Cloud Functions,
these separate parts
of your applications
can scale independently.
So if you have one
resource or endpoint
that's being used
heavily by your users,
or maybe you get a large amount
of events posted on Pub/Sub
or files stored in Cloud
Storage, all of those functions
can run independently from
the rest of your application.
So if you have resources that
your app uses on App Engine,
you don't necessarily
need all of those
to, say, resize an image.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah.
And so I've seen customers
who actually end up
doing things like
deploying a function
and building all kinds of
complicated routing into it.
And so their function
kind of grows
into this really big thing that
can do many different things.
But that's actually a
bit of an anti-pattern
when it comes to functions.
What we really
recommend is trying
to keep your code isolated
to a specific use case,
making sure that it does
one thing really well,
because that
simplicity, actually,
comes with a lot of benefits.
You know, Tyler
mentioned the scaling.
Another one is, if you look
at the logs for your function,
you know exactly, for each
execution, for each function,
what was happening if you're
printing stuff out to standard
out as you're going.
And so that simplicity
gives you a very easy way
to reason about, where
are my failure points?
Where's my scaling?
What's my usage
for specific tasks?
That isolation, I think,
is a very big benefit
of Cloud Functions.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds great.
Actually, speaking
of App Engine,
and having done a lot
of work with App Engine,
if I'm writing Go code in
App Engine, I write my code,
and I run, like,
gcloud app deploy.
And it bundles it all up,
and it sends it up somewhere
to build it all.
Is that experience similar
to what happens on Functions?
Like, do you build the
actual thing for me?
Or do I have to build a
binary and ship it somewhere?
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah,
so we follow the same model
as for App Engine.
You give a source code,
we run that for you.
You don't really have to
think about the build step.
But since you're asking,
you gcloud functions
deploy, pass a couple
command-line flags,
everything in your directory
gets uploaded via that CLI,
and we, then, build
that function according
to what you've given us.
So if you've given
us a go.mod file,
we're going to install
those dependencies.
It's all going to be built
into a container that, then,
runs on our infrastructure.
You don't, typically, have
to think about these details,
but it's good to know.
If you give us a
vendor directory,
we're going to
build that for you.
And so we really want to handle
all kinds of different shapes
and sizes of Go code that
people want to give us.
And we want to make sure
that you don't actually have
to think about the build step.
All of that is handled for you.
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH: The
two other common ways
that you can deploy
Functions are with,
one, in the Cloud Console.
So there is an
editor there which
might work for very small
functions or limited changes.
But it does work, and it's
nice for getting started.
And then, the other option
is you can upload a zip file.
So if, for whatever
reason, you would
prefer not to deploy from, say,
the gcloud command-line tool,
you can upload a zip file
and say, build the function
from there.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah.
And so the UI-based
use case, we actually
see a lot of people using
that as their entry point
to the product.
You go to
console.google.com/functions.
You click Create Function.
You click Deploy.
It's, literally, two clicks, and
you've got a function running.
It's a great way
to get your first,
sort of, step into the product.
But once you graduate beyond
that, as Tyler mentioned,
you can deploy with
the gcloud CLI.
We also have an API that
you can deploy against.
You can also do integrations
like the zip file upload.
MARK MANDEL: So one
thing I love asking you--
I think this is going to be fun.
So why would people
choose Go Cloud Functions
over other languages in Cloud
Functions that we support?
STEWART REICHLING:
Yeah, so that's
a great question, and
a question that I also
have to think about often,
which is why do we even
support these new languages?
We already have Node.
Can't everyone just write Node?
Well, the fact of the
matter is that not everybody
wants to write Node.
People want to write
in the language that's
most familiar to them.
It makes it very
easy to get started.
And alluding to
that earlier when
I said we don't want
you to have to learn
a whole bunch of new stuff--
well, if I tell you,
hey, use Cloud Functions,
and before you do, learn Node,
that's a pretty big hurdle.
MARK MANDEL: That's literally
what I went through.
[LAUGHS]
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah,
and so that's not great.
I mean Node's a great language.
It's got a great
community around it.
But we want to make sure that
this is as easy and intuitive
to you as possible.
The other thing that,
actually, I think,
there's that familiarity.
The other piece is, just
as I mentioned earlier,
picking the right
tool for the job--
different languages have
different characteristics.
So what we've seen
with Go is often
you can find optimizations
in terms of speed,
in terms of execution
performance.
And so you might want to pick
the right language for the job
based on its performance
characteristics, the ecosystem
of packages that
exists around it,
the types of people that
work at your company
and their familiarity
and their desire
to work with that language.
MARK MANDEL: I was hoping
for way more flame war stuff,
but that's cool.
That's good, too.
STEWART REICHLING: [LAUGHS].
AJA HAMMERLY: So
basically, you're
trying to meet folks where they
are with the problems they have
and the tools
they're familiar with
and make it an easy
on-ramp for everyone.
I approve.
I think that's amazing.
STEWART REICHLING:
Yeah, exactly.
And I think that the
best thing we can do,
then, is we come to you and
we say, hey, you write Go.
Well, you can write
Go on this thing.
And by the way, it
looks and feels like Go.
It's idiomatic.
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH:
Yeah, I think
that's the same
principle that goes into,
let's say, for HTTP functions,
where it's just a HandlerFunc.
And it's the same
guiding principle
for, you shouldn't need to
learn Cloud Functions Go.
It's just you know
Go, or you like Go,
or you're learning Go,
or none of the above.
And you shouldn't have to do
something special just for this
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah.
And just to throw a
little teaser out there,
because I know some people
aren't as interested in Go
as they might be
in other languages,
we're working on other
language, as well.
You should expect to see more
language support in the future.
Google Cloud supports a
broad range of languages,
and we want to conform to that.
AJA HAMMERLY: So
that's a lovely segue
into asking, so what comes
next for Go Cloud Functions?
So Go 1.11 is in beta right now.
That means we still
have polish work
to do, both on the reliability
side, on the performance side.
Faster deployment
times, for example,
is one of the pieces of
feedback we've received.
We want to give
better error messages.
One of the nice
things about being
in a serverless
environment is that you
don't have to think about
the infrastructure that's
underneath.
But one of the downsides
is that you can't really
just SSH into a
machine and necessarily
figure out what's going on.
And because you don't
have that control,
giving back meaningful
error messages
is super important, because the
worst thing is something breaks
and you have no way of
figuring out what happened.
So for us, there's a lot
of work on the polish side.
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH:
With serverless, it
is a bit of a black box
of what that machine is,
and you don't know
what's happening.
And you make whatever
API calls, and you don't
know how long they're taking.
And so a good way to debug
that, and a general, just,
development piece of advice,
is to use tracing and logging,
in general.
And so tracing,
as a quick primer,
is you can trace the function
calls and API calls that you're
making from your code and
say this Translation API took
150 milliseconds to
compute, or to respond,
so it's not worth really looking
into this if my user code only
added 10 milliseconds to this.
There isn't much
optimization to add.
MARK MANDEL: And there's
a library for that.
Right?
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH: Yeah.
So there's something
called OpenCensus which
is an open source library.
It's mainly sponsored
by Google and Microsoft,
where you can export to
whatever tracing, visualization,
and debugging provider
that you prefer.
So for Google
that's Stackdriver,
but there are many
other offerings
that do the same thing.
MARK MANDEL: And we even have
a podcast on it-- episode 118.
STEWART REICHLING: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Favorite
question I also like to ask--
what's the most
interesting thing
you've seen so far people
build with Go Cloud
Functions-- or wacky,
or just plain strange?
STEWART REICHLING: So there's
a very interesting company
out of Europe in
the farming space
that I spoke with recently.
And they do
something really cool
where they have a bunch of
different IoT devices sitting
in their farms, each with
variable degrees of high speed
internet.
And those are emitting events
about the state of the farms--
so temperature
readings, humidity.
And all of that data gets
fed to a message bus which
feeds into Pub/Sub
and then triggers
Cloud Functions that run in
response to those readings.
And so Cloud Functions is
a very useful piece of glue
there, where you can take
that data, put it somewhere
where it's more
persistent, and now you
have a pretty reliable way
of seeing, in one state, OK,
what is the state of my farm?
What does everything look like?
And so you get Cloud
Functions as glue code,
but also handling
data and making
those use cases very easy
through very simple bits
of code.
You know, you're talking about
less than 100 lines of code
to set this whole thing up.
MARK MANDEL: Tyler, you
got anything, as well?
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH: I don't
think anything specific.
But just commenting on
Pub/Sub and just the things
that people can push through
it and the amount of execution
that can go through it and
be triggered and scaled
automatically with, as
Stewart said, very little code
that you've actually written--
it's just really cool to see.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah,
it's pretty mind-blowing
when you see the
types of things people
are able to build when you give
them these simple primitives
and good integrations, things
like, hey, every time something
happens to my Firestore, I want
to run some code in response
to that.
People can come up with
some pretty amazing things
when you just give
them those pieces.
Hey, can I shout out some more
stuff that's coming up for Go?
We're working on Go 1.12,
so expect that sometime
in the near future.
It'll be pretty
similar to Go 1.11.
There will be some improvements.
We're putting in all
this work to make sure
that we are respecting
the language communities
and really supporting
the language.
We want to make sure
that we also stay current
with the language versions.
MARK MANDEL: So that
sounds really great.
If people are like,
this sounds awesome,
and they want to learn stuff
about Go Cloud Functions,
where should people go?
Are there some good resources
that people can take advantage
of?
STEWART REICHLING: Three things.
The first is we had
a pretty cool launch
video for this runtime.
You can see it on
YouTube right now.
Search Go Cloud Functions,
should pop right up.
MARK MANDEL: We'll put
it in the links, too.
STEWART REICHLING: It walks
you through the basic types
of functions, how to
deploy, what the experience
looks like from gcloud.
It's about five minutes long.
It's a great way to get started.
I'd also recommend
the quickstarts.
So go to the docs page.
We'll have a link to that below.
That will, basically,
walk you through-- if I'm
a good developer, how
do I go from having
no code to using gcloud to
deploying my first Go function?
And the last thing
I'd shout out is
if you only have a
couple of minutes,
the quickest way
to get started--
go to the Cloud Console.
Go to the Functions page.
Click Create Function.
Select the Go runtime.
It will give you a
pre-populated snippet of code
that you can deploy.
Click Deploy.
You're going to get a url.
You can invoke it.
I'd say that's the easiest
way to go from nothing
to actually trying the
product out, having
your first experience with
it, in less than five minutes.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, Tyler,
Stewart, thank you so
much for joining
us on the podcast
today and telling us all
about Go Cloud Functions.
STEWART REICHLING: Yeah.
Thanks for having us.
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH: Yeah.
Thank you.
AJA HAMMERLY: So thanks
again to Stewart and Tyler
for joining us on the
podcast today and teaching us
all about Go Cloud Functions.
There's a lot of exciting
stuff going on there.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So we have a question of
the week, as per always.
And I get to ask you a
question of the week.
Hahaha.
So the question of the
week is how many ways
can you run containers
on Google Cloud Platform?
AJA HAMMERLY: I believe
the answer is 4.
[DING]
MARK MANDEL: OK.
AJA HAMMERLY: This is
something that I discovered
a couple of years
ago, and I have
found that most people
actually haven't figured out.
Everyone knows about Kubernetes
because Kubernetes is awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
AJA HAMMERLY: A fair
number of people
know about App Engine Flexible--
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
AJA HAMMERLY: --where
you can run containers,
which is how you
can run languages
that we don't support fully.
But maybe you really want to run
a COBOL container or something
for your application.
So that's one and two.
And what a lot of
people don't know
is that you can actually
run containers straight up
on Google Compute Engine.
So you can run them either
as part of a managed instance
group, or you can
actually just deploy
a VM based on a container image.
It's really handy
if you just need
to spin up a single
instance of a container.
And we're going to
have a link in the show
notes to more information
about this on a document that's
actually been updated relatively
recently because this is still
a really common use
case that people have.
And if you don't need all of
the really cool orchestration
abilities and discoverability
abilities of Kubernetes,
this is another way
to run containers that
is absolutely 100% supported.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
AJA HAMMERLY: The
other super cool thing
is the managed instance groups
support both health tracking
and autoscaling.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
AJA HAMMERLY: So you
get some of the benefits
of an orchestration tool
but not all of them.
But it's a lot lighter weight.
So it's a good choice for
some folks, not for everyone.
MARK MANDEL: So I
think you said four.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yes.
So we have Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: Kubernetes.
App Engine Flexible.
AJA HAMMERLY: App
Engine Flexible.
MARK MANDEL: GCE.
AJA HAMMERLY: As
a standalone VM.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
AJA HAMMERLY: And as part
of a managed instance group.
MARK MANDEL: Ah, fantastic.
[DING]
MARK MANDEL: One,
two, three, four.
AJA HAMMERLY: Sorry, I'm
counting compute engines twice
because it's that awesome.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
That's all right.
One, two, three, four.
[ORGAN NOTE]
MARK MANDEL: Hahaha.
Sorry, I had to
get that in there.
Awesome.
Well, Aja, what are you up to?
What have you been doing
that's cool and interesting,
or things that people
can look forward to?
AJA HAMMERLY: Oh, I've been in
my winter hibernation phase.
And I don't actually
have any conferences
planned until Google
Cloud Next in April.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah?
What are you doing at Next?
AJA HAMMERLY: Right now?
Nothing.
My actual contribution
at Next this year
is I'm helping
represent our developer
attendees as part of our
sessions curation process.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, fantastic.
AJA HAMMERLY: So I'm making
sure that our story has
all the stuff that everyone
who listens to this podcast
wants to learn.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
AJA HAMMERLY: And
make sure we're
having really good
stories for all
of our wonderful
technical practitioners
who come join us every year for
our big party in San Francisco.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
that sounds good.
Well, I'll be speaking
at Cloud Next, as well,
which will be great.
I'm looking forward to that.
Two weeks before Next, I will
be at a rather small conference
called Game
Developers Conference.
It's just 30,000 people.
It'll be fine.
We'll be doing some
cloud sessions there.
There'll be a mobile dev day.
There'll be a cloud dev day,
all sorts of good stuff.
We'll have a link to that
in the show notes, as well.
And just after all of
that, actually, I'll
be also presenting at East
Coast Game Conference,
talking about Agones and
talking about open source,
in general, particularly how it
relates to the games industry.
One thing I do want
to shout out that's
really cool that I got
really excited about,
because I work on Agones,
and that project-- we just
released our new website.
If you go to agones.dev,
it's all pretty and stuff.
It uses a theme that actually
came out of a Google called
[INAUDIBLE].
So huge thanks to
that team, as well.
So if you're looking
for a good way
to do open source docs for
your next open source project,
it's really, really nice.
And it takes away a
lot of the pain points
of trying to build a site that's
very particular for open source
and documentation and
all that good stuff.
Oh, yeah.
I started Twitch streaming
again a bit, too.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
AJA HAMMERLY: That
will be so cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I'm going to try and
keep that up while I'm
in Australia in a few weeks.
So--
[ROBOTIC NOISE]
AJA HAMMERLY: Hey, everyone can
watch who review poll requests
and make stuff better
and write code and--
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
AJA HAMMERLY: --solve problems.
It's always fantastic to
watch everyone else's process
and realize that I'm not the
only one who occasionally
bangs my head against the wall.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
I mess things up all the time.
[GLASS SHATTERING]
That's literally my
entire Twitch stream.
AJA HAMMERLY: Sounds awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, Aja, thank you for joining
me on the podcast this week.
AJA HAMMERLY: Thank you for
letting me co-host, Mark.
This was a lot of fun.
I hope to be back soon.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And thank you everyone
for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]